because after I dropped out got
martial-arts then I got involved in in
the in both my spiritual explorations
meditation spiritual practices people
you know that were involved in sort of
understanding multiple levels of the
universe and seemed to have quite a
knowledge of how to do that and then I
had my own personal experiences that
validated a whole lot of what I'd so
kind of intuited all along which is hey
there's a bigger game out there with
them we can see and it's it's weird it's
in all of us where it we are all engaged
in it but you you don't have to you
don't have to wait to die to find out
what it is what was that experience was
this how I had many of them but they
were you know they were an awful lot
about sort of letting myself kind of go
out of the body and be in in and see
things in another way from a whole
different perspective which is it was
not drug related it was really just more
the ability to be able to do that and a
lot of it kind of happened not that I
was that conscious of it you know I had
a great spiritual coach really a guy
named John Roger that I worked with you
know he was I explored a lot of
different people and a lot of what they
were doing tried to pull a lot of
different things ran across John Roger
and you know this guy seemed to have
gone down the path that I was on but a
lot further than hype that I had gone
but he was the kind of guy that's you
know you meet people like that the way
he talks you know he doesn't he doesn't
really care if anybody believes him or
not he just knows the truth of what he
was doing and I sort of very much
resonated with him I say hang out with
this guy and see what he learns until
like to like sort of run through all
that and then I'll go find something
else I'm I never ran through all that
after 45 years and he died about five
years ago so that that was the basis of
my spiritual work and practices and
essentially as I got involved in that my
my my inner life got richer my outer
life kind of slowed down you know I
experimented with a lot of different
drugs they put me away in a mental
institution for a short period of time
because yeah I was then I demonstrated
aberrated behavior well no we almost
lost you you know so just real quickly
to interject last year
I ran my first Ironman race and I had to
go to New York City to train for it and
in the process of making the movie I
started talking about my my heroin
overdose from 2001 when I was in New
York City and I had had that in the
notes for our last interview but I
hadn't actually ever told anyone about
it including my wife until last year and
so um and it's been interesting for
people to say wow I never thought that
that would happen to you Brian because
you seemed to be the guy that that
doesn't happen to and it was registering
for me to talk about because it can
happen to anybody just kind of the drugs
and the addiction and stuff and we
almost lost you there briefly right well
actually not really but I I wasn't doing
any of those things as escape I was
doing them at for exploration I was
fascinated by acid you know LSD I was
fascinated by mescaline I was fascinated
by even grass and by the just the
consciousness because I was very much
into what's the other consciousness that
you can get into and tap into so you
know I it was those days they were
talking the sixties so that was you know
that was just kind of like well so who
wasn't doing anything like that so mine
and I never yes I snorted smack for
about a year in a year and a half and
when I decided to stop I just stopped
and didn't have to go through withdrawal
and I had a kind of a bad cold and that
was it
so I wasn't really and it's tricky
because as you know it's it's quite
seductive yeah quite seductive funny
knows no matter how bad you feel it
makes you feel good right and that's
that's a that's why this opioid thing is
so is so you know I don't know if it's
scary but it's certainly it's quite
understandable why a whole lot of people
you know get wound up involved in all
that yeah but so all those things
actually added to a lot of different
experiences that I had and so I wouldn't
I wouldn't give any of them up because
they you know I wound up getting you
know where I am now through all those
things and rungs of the ladder and in a
way and the psychedelics for a big part
of it as well well they just kind of
fried my nervous system so I wasn't able
to monitor things quite so well and so
you know I went through a period where I
was hearing voices I was seeing things
you know that they were showing up and
you know from my experience and other
things they
not necessarily unreal and so and I
started to get kind of mad at the world
because I could see I I was in a way so
psychically you know tuned I could tell
what was going on in people's heads just
being around him and feel what they were
feeling and and that was not that fun
to be able to do that but I also saw
people you know that were doing really
weird things and whatever and I started
to call people on it and they got mad
and angry and I got angry at them for
not believing me and so I just kind of
got pissed off at the world and pushed
up against it and at some point you know
people saw I was doing kind of strange
things so they wound up putting me away
Wow so but I never actually and even
then and by the way I escaped I said I
don't need I don't need to be here and
so I actually jumped over the wall you
know hitchhiked back to Berkeley then
they went and caught me again and
putting it back putting me back in
maximum security that was not fun so
then I decided instead of railing
against the world I think I will
cooperate with it so I tell people now
you I'm not any less crazy you're
looking at a high state of cooperation
[Laughter]